we are told liam multiplies two numbers
and gets an even product
what could be true about the numbers
liam multiplied it says choose two
answers so pause this video and see if
you can figure out which two of these
could be true all right now let's do
this together and we have to think about
what could be true they don't have to be
true that just has to be possible
okay now is it possible that both
numbers were even can you multiply two
even numbers and get an even product
well sure and i can imagine examples
that get us there if you multiply two
times four which is equal to eight you
have an even times an even that gets you
an even in fact in general when you
multiply two evens together you will get
an even product
and so
this is definitely this definitely could
be true
both numbers were odd
you might remember
that an odd times an odd is always going
to be an odd or you could look at a few
examples and feel pretty confident
that's the case if you multiply 3
times 5 that's equal to 15. odd times
odd is equal to an odd number if you
multiply
7
times 9 you get 63 once again odd times
odd is equal to odd so there's no way
that you can multiply two odd numbers
and get an even product so we would rule
this out
one number was even and one number was
odd
well let's think about what happens when
you multiply an even times an odd if i
multiply 2 times 3 that's equal to 6
so you have an even i'll just put an e
there times an odd is equal to an even
and so the two ways that you can get an
even product is either if you're
multiplying an even times an even or an
even times an odd essentially an even
times either an even or an odd is going
to get you an even product let's do
another example
we're asked which of the following have
an even product it says once again
choose two answers so pause this video
again and see if you can figure it out
okay eight fives so eight fives is the
same thing as eight times five and this
is a situation where we're multiplying
an even e for even times an odd which
we've already talked about is going to
give us an even result an even product
you don't even have to know that 8 times
5 is 40 which is an even number we have
an even times an odd which is going to
give us an even product so this will
definitely give us an even product
an odd number
times an even number well we've already
talked about that any either an odd or
an even times an even is going to give
you an even product so we can
fill that one in and then 5 times 3 you
have an odd times an odd which is going
to give you an odd number
even if you didn't know that this is
going to be 15 you would know that an
odd times an odd is always going to give
you an odd product not an even product
so we would pick these first two